>> Steve: THEY BROUGHT TH
YET.
MESSING AT CENTER, HUBERDEAU,
PUTTINIT DID NOT TAKE THEM LONG
THAT, AND THE NATIONAL
PREDATORS, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
THEM GET CAUGHTHTSTART
OF THE GAME,
CHANGED  DIRECTION.
HERE IS A GOOD LOOK AT
, ON BENNETT.
GIVE HIM ANY TIME AT ALL, HEIT
WITH A SHOOTING
POSITION.
AND THERE IS WHERE HE WANTS TO
GOAL, EYE-LOCK ON THE
PUCK.
YOU WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS,  AS
SCORES, UPSTAIRS, , MISTAKE.
WHAT AN INDIVIDUAL EFFORT, YOU
WILL SEE A ROCKET OF A BACKEND.
THE ONLY OPTION HE HAS.
IN, TAK
EAGER TO GET TO TO GET
SAM BENNETT, SIX  GAME-WINNING
GOALS, HE BELIEVE THAT LINE, TH
OF THE PANTHERS.
HERE IS THE SHOT, IT WAS
PARTIALLY BLACK, AND THE SEE
RIGHT THERE.
BOBROVSKY, WIS 4-4.
5:48 TO GO, AND IT HAS BEEN  NA
HATHE  BLUE
LINE, BLOCKS THE CLEARING
THEY SCORE.
TANNER JEANNOT, HIS